>> THESE ARE MOMMY'S CO-WORKERS.
CAN YOU SAY HI?
>> WHAT'S UP, BUDDY, YOU'RE
LOOKING FRESH.
>> HEY, YOU LOOK NICE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GIVE ME A HIGH FIVE, BUDDY.
OW, TOO STRONG.
>> I BET YOU PLAYED FOOTBALL,
RIGHT?
>> YEAH, AT SCHOOL.
THAT SUCKS.
YOU WEAR YOUR CLOTHES TO SCHOOL?
>> YOU HAVE NO IDEA HOW TO TALK
TO CHILDREN?
DOES IT MAKE YOU FEEL LIKE A BAD
PERSON THAT YOU CAN'T?
IT'S NEVER TOO LATE TO LEARN.
WITH NEW DUO LINGO FOR TALKING
TO CHILDREN.
THE FIRST APP FOR GROWN PEOPLE
WHO NEED TO LEARN HOW TO TALK TO
KIDS BECAUSE THEIR FRIENDS ARE
STARTING TO HAVE THEM.
PRACTICE JUST FIVE MINUTES A DAY
AND YOU'LL BE A BRAT WHISPERER
IN NO TIME.
>> VERY COOL, BUD.
VERY COOL, BUD.
>> CHICKEN FINGERS.
CHICKEN FINGERS.
>> I LIKE YOUR BACKPACK.
>> THE ONE THING YOU KNOW ABOUT
TALKING TO KIDS IS YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO CALL GIRLS PRETTY BUT
THEN IT'S LIKE, "WHAT DO YOU
SAY?"
>> YOU LOOK NOT PRETTY BUT
--
I MEAN, YOU'RE SMART.
I MEAN, YOU'RE AN ENGINEER ONE
DAY.
>> ARE YOU OKAY?
>> I GOT THIS.
JUST ONE SECOND, SORRY.
COOL BACKPACK.
>> GET A BETTER SENSE OF KIDS.
>> GET A BETTER SENSE OF KIDS'
AGES.
>> IDENTIFY THE 12-YEAR-OLD.
CORRECT!
>> PRACTICE TRADITIONAL
GREETING.
>> I GOT YOUR NOSE!
>> BUILD YOUR STAMINA FOR LONG,
MEANDERING, POINTLESS STORIES.
>> I REALLY LIKE THE PIZZA THEY
HAVE TOO.
>> COOL!
>> IN AS LITTLE AS SIX WEEKS
YOU'LL BE READY FOR ALL KINDS OF
KINDER CONVERSATIONS LIKE
FRIENDS NEW BABY, THE BUS, DANCE
RECITALS, CHILD FALLS ON
SIDEWALK IN FRONT OF YOU, PUBLIC
RESTAURANTS, AIRPORT GATES, HOT
TUB AT VACATION RESORTS, AND
CHILD WEARING BIG PINK DRESS.
LET'S FACE IT.
KIDS ARE BAD CONVERSATIONALISTS.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE.
>> SO I BET YOU LIKE CHICKEN
FINGERS.
>> HEY, HIGH FIVE.
TOO SLOW.
>> DUO LINGO FOR TALKING TO
KIDS, ALSO AVAILABLE IN --